well hi everyone my name is ash carlson
and over the next half hour we're going
to be talking about the mandalorian
season two unanswered questions from
season one predictions and
all of those pesky rumored castings and
cameos and all of that and
i think i've assembled a pretty great
team to chat with so we have joining me
today
entertainment reporter and assistant
producer for looking for leia katrina
dennis
thank you thanks for having me josh we
have entertainment reporter for io9 and
gizmodo jermaine lucier
hello everybody thanks ash and film
writer for vanity fair anthony breast
again
hey guys you know this is no place for a
child
[Music]
so how's everyone feeling about season
two is the hype there for you again guys
how you feeling jermaine uh yes and no i
mean it's
as we're recording this it's about two
weeks away and
i i'm excited for it because you gotta
know it's coming but i also
don't feel like the hype for it because
and it's not even just quarantine it's
just i see the same
i saw one tv commercial we've had one
trailer it's got about seven shots in it
and lucasfilm is obviously very
secretive about these kind of things but
it doesn't feel like it's two weeks away
it feels like it's two months away and
we're just about to start
not see the whole thing in two weeks as
a star wars fan i'm always excited as a
pedro pascal fan i'm extremely excited
as a fan of yobito i am super excited
but otherwise i'm kind of like
well i feel like i'm going to be more
excited when i actually know what's
happening
and going on and yeah so once i'm in it
i feel like it's going to be there
i'm right with you guys i i'm
excited to have this to watch but
there's nothing to be excited about yet
i thought the trailer was
relatively bland it felt like i mean it
was cool seeing the gammarian guard
wrestlers or boxers or whatever they are
or gladiators
uh apart from that it all felt like it
could be
like scenes from season one and i know
that the
john favreau wants to keep it locked
down um
but there's not much to be hyped about
just yet uh
i'm i'm waiting for those things that
will make it exciting of course we'll
all tune in and see then and i feel like
even last season
it was like a last minute thing where
they were like oh maybe we should like
pull back the curtain on this just a
little bit
and build some hype but it wasn't until
like right before that that started
happening
well but at least you had new things
like oh we see the mandalorian for the
first time like in april
back at star wars celebration and we
didn't know anything about baby yoda but
like
you saw scenes and you heard music and
there were things that felt fresh and
new
i just i i don't i don't feel i feel
like it's just sort of like you know
something is coming but you don't know
what it is so it's just hard to feel
like
a lot of excitement i guess i'll tune in
to watch it's almost like the
that was the appetizer last time because
we had a rise of skywalker coming a
month later
and i was like oh we get these two big
things now mandalorian has to carry
all of it because we're not going to get
a star wars movie until 2022 2023 who
knows
so i feel like it's holding more weight
there hasn't been that wow moment yet
it strangely feels like my heart is
still in season one because i had that
big juicy promotional sandwich of like
celebration and then the series and then
after that we had the making of uh
series as well so and that was just like
so cool
and if i even if i had gotten a little
more bts i think by now
i i'd probably be a lot more interested
so
just looking back at season one what
would you guys say katrina what's your
biggest
unanswered question from season one that
you hope is addressed in season two
we're gonna we're gonna discuss this
later i'm sure but uh uh
fennec shand is a big big thing uh for
my heart
and uh whoever was approaching her
that's just kind of stuck with
me since episode five so really
really interested in where that's going
i'm with you so
[ __ ] when everyone was really
disappointed for her to come in and
out in an episode and you know that
thing where it's like you don't see a
body they're probably not dead but in
star wars it's like you can see the body
you can see them get chopped in half
that does not mean they are dead
so i'm holding out that she is still
alive i think she
probably is still alive i just they
didn't put those boots in there for
nothing you know
like they seated that for a big reason
you know
who or what that is we don't know but
you don't end an episode like that
going up to a character like that and
and don't forget that also the episode
where they go to tatooine and it's just
filled with the nostalgia like on
overload like almost too much
um so yeah if so i i think she'll
fit back in but i mean you also never
know yeah i really want to see her come
back she was one of my favorite
characters from
season one uh yeah if you get mignogen
to do something you better let her run
with it a little more i want to know
more about that character i want to see
her do more badass stuff
in some ways she fell a little bit
victim to
the boba fett trap uh because
she's this cool looking character who
has a neat backstory but not
we don't actually get to see her do
anything super cool like she gets kind
of captured and killed right away
uh and those boots i mean we do we do
know what that is
that's boba fett's uniform at the very
least
the that jingle jangle of his spurs is
the same exact sound that boba fett had
and empire strikes back so you don't do
that by accident either whether it's
boba fett in those boots
we will find out but it's clearly meant
to imply some connection to boba fett
imply but i mean we did see that guy go
down uh
you know the sarlacc pit where he's
supposed to be digested for a thousand
years star wars has been resurrecting
boba fett
ever since he went into that pit you
know there's short stories about him
escaping
you know the uh the novels by chuck
wendig
created this whole other character who
finds the armor and puts it on
protects his town so like you could
weave that character in
i think that would be a little bit
disappointing like
maybe it'll be cool for chuck wendy to
see his character on the screen but like
i wanted i want i would like to see boba
fett come back
you know i feel like i would like to see
boba fett but
you know like you said they had done
they had done a lot of short stories
they've revived him a million times when
they revive him
in canon as people refer to it
i feel like it needs to be a big deal
like
because it's the thing that a lot of
fans have been waiting for so not only
does it need to be a big deal
it needs to be really well written so i
don't know if i feel like that's boba
fett
with all the rumors that we're going to
get into a little bit that's kind of
feels like the danger with season two
right like
is we hear that maybe tomorrow morrison
is back as boba fett we hear
maybe rosario dawson's playing so katana
and all these major characters and
you're like
you're gonna fit all this into eight
episodes those characters are all so
massive
to fans and like we are what was great
about season one
is it was a pretty streamlined kind of
show about
this bouncy hunter and his child and the
child has a whole other thing
that's really fascinating but that was
it you know so i
i'm that's one of the dangers i think
they might fall into here we'll have to
see
if the original season felt very much
like the serials that inspired star wars
in
the first place where it's less like a
tv series i mean there's a connecting
thread
but it's like they're so idiosyncratic
each episode
is its own little self-contained story
that it felt like you're following the
mandalorian as he has
various adventures rather than one
connected story where the all the
characters mingle and interact
i also think one danger of the
um the under wraps hype that they're
trying to generate by not showing
anything not talking about anything
uh and just waiting for it to drop is
that you you end up letting the fan
imaginations run wild and star wars has
fallen into this again and again and
again absolutely you get so
hyped about the return of emperor
palpatine
that you that nothing they present can
match what your imagination has done and
i think that's a danger
for creatives is letting the fans write
their own story
in advance and then you can't help but
underwhelm them so i think
they should manage that a little bit
better the second that one of these
hollywood trades breaks
a casting thing they should say no if
it's not you know
and if they and so because like if
socatano is in this
it would be cool to know and just get
kind of get excited about it but the
uncertainty yeah
you build like oh my god is it going to
be all about her are we going to tie
into rebels
is sabine going to be in it are we going
to see ezra are we going to see thrawn
and then you just
your mind just keeps going when really
if she's in there maybe she pops up and
the end of season episode eight and says
like i can help you with that baby and
it's like credits you know like that
might be all it is
that's a bummer uh you know i thought uh
ryan johnson did a really smart thing
when
the last jedi was coming out in an
interview with him
i said look people want to know is lando
calrissian coming back
we've brought back so many of the other
classic characters you're going to a
casino world
seems like lando's natural habitat uh
any chance we'll see billy d william and
he goes
absolutely not i want to go on the
record with this now like
lando is not in this i don't want fans
to expect him and then be disappointed
when they don't get it and i think
look i don't expect them to come out and
say yes ahsoka tano is in the show
yes we're going to reveal uh
this character or that character like if
you have certain surprises built in fine
i thought the baby yoda reveal worked
really well but
if you're going to say nothing and fans
are going to get hyped for these
characters
and expect them to be major parts of the
show and if they're not
that's a bummer and you've gotta then
you have to live with the disappointment
of that
do you guys think that rosario dawson is
in fact playing
ahsoka in the show i think she is i
think she is
i think so yeah that's a good good
casting
it's the best thing that that like star
wars fans asked for
like 10 years ago i want to say yeah
like or even 5.
i didn't interview with her last like a
year ago
and i was like are you ever going to be
in star wars and she was like oh the
fans have been pushing for me to play
sokatana for a while now and i was like
why are you saying that
randomly and then like like six months
later i asked her again
and she was like i can't confirm or deny
anything it's fine to do that it's just
if she's in it for two seconds as
jermaine says yeah great job hyping it
up
unless it's she's the dark saber of this
season like i said that's
that's my that's my bold prediction that
sokatano is the uh
is the tease of what's to come next
season
my thing i think that's probably
accurate anthony do you have a biggest
fun answer question from season one
biggest unanswered question i'd like to
know where baby yoda comes from
did you call him yodito
the latinx branch of the fandom has like
mildly adopted
that was good that was that's mine too i
mean
that was such a big reveal for so many
reasons and
it's become you know a very cute thing
but from a
pure star wars mythology the fact that
there is a third
member of yoda's race out there that's
strong with the force at this time
after yoda's dead has such implications
for what could be happening and not the
not the next
two episode seasons of the mandalorian
but the next
two decades of star wars the promise
there is so big
filoni knows it favro knows it and i
think they're going to play it close and
tight
where did he come from who were his
parents what his powers
what is his destiny all of it i have so
many questions about
mock gideon because i was just
re-watching the finale and i don't think
it struck me at first off gideon he
committed war crimes like he's not alive
and i'm like
who is this dude like what's his whole
backstory
he pillaged an entire uh you know race
of people
and stole their most powerful relic how
did that happen
yeah that's what i want to know like
what what happened between
rebels and now to have him possess the
dark saber
or is it even the original dark saber
like you know
pretty hard to forge but you know
everything can be copied
but do you remember in um in uh rogue
one
when they go up to get the uh whatever
the document file on this
on the death star they uh um they see
all those files and isn't the dark saber
like listed as one of the like secret
projects that the empire was involved
with
i think so i yeah i think it's the real
dark saber we saw sabine give it to boca
tan
and then now he's got it so but again
that leads to another rumor
so jermaine what is your biggest hope
for season two i think this is it might
be my like uh
my fan hat i'd like to see it become
more of dave filoni show
and the the casting sort of is
suggesting that meaning
we're seeing these clone wars characters
may be coming in we're seeing these
rebels characters may be coming in
we're seeing all these stories that
falloni's been seeding since 2008 9
whenever
he started getting on clone wars you
know the dark saber being the first big
thing of that
and i think short of george lucas
polonie is
the god of star wars so uh and i think
favreau kind of realizes that and i
think he's kind of maybe
like giving him a little bit more rope
with the story and that's that's my hope
is that we're gonna see
it get uh a little deeper into the lore
and because that's my favorite stuff but
on the other hand you know it's a show
for mass audiences it's not a book
for star wars fans so i think they have
a a really
fine line to them anthony what's your
biggest hope for season two
uh my biggest hope for season two is
that we get a reason to keep watching
for season three
like i i think if it's just on the run
for
seven seasons that that's gonna get
tired it's like the a team right like
they're just on the run constantly
uh and i feel like if they treat this as
a trilogy
say three seasons this is chapter two
can you do an empire strikes back thing
with it where
you get a sense of uh
you know the stakes are raised right
that's what you do in act two is you
act one establishes uh the characters
and the situation and then act two like
puts them in peril
and and raises uh all the challenges
around them so like i hope that it
doesn't end the same way that season one
ended with just
uh the mandalorian and the child on on
the run
katrina how about you i am holding out
hope for more
mandalorians uh i'm i'm worried about
what happened to them
um because so many of them weren't dead
if not almost all
i i'm really interested in what din and
his relation to his culture is now that
he's watched
like that massacre he's gone through
that like asajj ventress moment where
like all of his people are dead and
now he has to move forward so i'm really
focused on along with
baby yoda uh dan i really care about him
so
i also wouldn't mind seeing some of the
unresolved questions from the sequel
trilogy
perhaps be resolved here you know bounty
hunters could also recover
objects and if we get some sort of
explanation about
the lightsaber how it ended up going
from cloud city to
you know uh
that'd be kind of neat but i don't
necessarily need that
yeah we never found that out did we no
there's more there was a little bit more
in some of the comics
um i don't remember specifically what
happened but yeah not we don't have a
whole
perfect there's still some gaps there
for sure okay let's get into
all the rumors all the casting rumors so
number one we saw sasha banks in the
trailer
and the internet immediately blew up
with the fact that she
is katrina i see you shaking your head
what do you think
sabine ren is an asian woman first and
foremost specifically because creators
in rebels even dave agreed with that
fact so i feel like it wouldn't
make sense for him to cast sasha um
but i'm very excited on that note to see
sasha banks in this series because
i'm a huge fan of parents and i think
she's going to bring something really
interesting
i hope she's evil also if you were going
to cast sabine ran
wouldn't you cast uh tia s your car like
yeah
she looks like sabine wren she voices
like
but they didn't cast ashley eckstein as
not hypothetically
i think sasha banks from what i've heard
maybe is some kind of other mandalorian
um good or evil i'm not sure not sabine
sabine obviously also um is that
but but the thing is i don't know why
sabine would be there but i also don't
know why ahsoka would be there
and at this point in the story they
might be together
as per the end of rebels they go up
together at the end of after the battle
of uh
you know endor it could make sense if
that piece of casting is true but yeah i
don't think sasha banks
we kind of touched on this but boba fett
is a big rumor do we think boba fett is
alive where are we
sure boba fett is alive somewhere um but
i'm sticking
i am sticking to the guns of those those
spurs belonging to
cobb vance who has his armor right
around that time so
yeah i i'm trying to parse the time
between aftermath and
when those uh when the mandalorian
occurs and
it's around that time that he is sheriff
of uh
freetown and um i also would just really
like it to become
pickup because cobb hired uh malakili
the rancor tamer
to herd uh his flock in town so it would
just be nice to see that
that's that's what i want this is a
super random
but i live in van nuys and i saw
tamara morrison about a year ago running
around like and
maybe he's just getting in shape and
just being healthy
so and i didn't even think about it i
saw him i was just like oh my god cool
and then like eight months later i was
like oh wait was he at that time maybe
getting back into star wars shape
because if he's back he's obviously you
know
boba fett is actually clone of jango
fett and so he could be playing
rex who is we know still alive at that
time uh again which would bring in the
filoni stuff
i i just feel like all these rumors that
we keep hearing are probably true
otherwise somebody would have come out
and said no
but i don't know you also got to think
star wars
films and tv shows do not geek out like
the books and comics do
because they keep it very much on the
surface they never go as deep as the
fans like to speculate
they don't they they just didn't even
explain how emperor palpatine came back
right
but but i think if if if timothy alathon
is playing cobb as everybody suspects
you don't need the full backstory i mean
i think he he's a
easy enough to understand surface
character within a story that you could
probably be like oh he just stole some
armor now he's trying to use it for good
but
now he's going to get you know his butt
kicked you know like that could be it
i'd like to see him come face to face
with boba fett
yes like i'd like my armor yes that's
what i want
i think that might yeah that seems like
where it could be going and that would
be super duper cool
that'd be cool so another rumor that
came out i think this more recent one is
katie sackoff is
bo katan what do we think
that's another like using the person to
play the character so yeah and also like
we said we had already said she's the
last person to have the dark saber and
the dark saber
is you know obviously going to be a huge
part of the show
it would make sense that she was on the
lookout for it has beef with mauve
gideon
etc etc i want to go into the trailer so
uh what did you guys get from the
trailer is there anything that you
predict from watching i know uh there's
we had
like brought up uh in preparation for
this like where amanda's taking
um i would just like to say i hope that
i don't think skywalker academy is open
yet but i sure hope he's not taking him
there
i'm really leaning toward the returning
into his people or
ahsoka and the gang show up and and
happened at the end of the series
so in i have a question in the timeline
where is the general public
with like the jedi they don't know they
exist at this point
yeah i i think that's an interesting
thing about star wars is like
while we see the movies and we see what
happens with the jedi and stuff
the mandalorian season is a great
example of like not everyone knows about
this stuff
the middle or didn't even know he'd
never even heard of like the force of
the jedi you know and he grew up as like
a great warrior there's so much else
going on so
what the galaxy knows about the jedi who
knows i mean it only took 19 years for
people to completely forget
or almost completely forget who the jedi
were and
or just think that they were awful so do
you guys think we're going gonna get
another baby yoda-esque moment
will we ever stop saying baby oda where
do we get the team yoda
well they said that he has like 90 of
them i think he's got a name but i think
like the child i don't think would ever
use it
unless it's like a real strong name you
know i don't know
even like yaddle is a better name than
baby yoda what
i'm never gonna stop yaddle i think kind
of
disrupts the whole thing i think yaddle
is a lame
character you put this toupee on a yoda
and stick it in the background
and say it's a lady yoda like i
i would i would bet anything that if
they could go back
dave fellaini be like george you don't
know me yet but don't put that character
in there please
but if you just just it's going to ruin
storytelling
way down the road and i think the fact
that there was this other jedi
of that race is and like do they all
have why
yoda yaddle like come on that's lame
yattle twitter is going to come for you
after
all the yaddle rose out there yeah
the same big reveal it's going to be in
regard to one of these casting rumors we
discussed
boba fett be much bigger be huge you'd
be bigger than soca as
much as her fans are so i don't want to
start anything
no do it i don't want anybody to go oh
he knows something
i don't know anything about this but has
time travel ever been an element of star
wars like could that potentially be
baby yoda and they got to get him back
to the future
somehow there was the world between
worlds it was more like moment travel
with the bridge
yeah yeah katrina's right there's an
episode of rebels where like you can
sort of jump between places
uh times and stuff so hypothetically
maybe i i kind of like that idea anthony
like it's better than it being like oh
we cloned yoda or this is
yoda and yaddle's love baby or there's a
whole planet of these
of these beings who aren't helping with
anything you know that's always
you know they're not helping yoda's
coolness derives from being unique
that's why yaddle ruins it in some ways
and it's cool that there's a baby yoda
and that but but if there weren't
another yoda
critter we would be way more into like
where did this thing come from so i
don't know i just made me wonder like is
there going to be so
you know we use the force to time like
time travel will become a new force
power or something
i hadn't heard that theory but i like it
a lot time travel though
it totally screws up every narrative
like because then you can just keep
going back and changing things and fix
it like
it's tough it's tough to pull off yeah i
agree
does anyone have any bold predictions
for season two
jermaine you kind of touched on yours i
think if we know from the end of the
last season and a little bit in the
trailer that
den is out trying to bring the child to
people who know what his power is
and i think of the people who we know
are in the galaxy at that moment
ahsoka tano knows more about the force
than anybody
so i think it would be super duper cool
and i said that like twice in the zoom
and i feel terrible about it
um that uh
that it sort of ends with he finds this
jedi named ahsoka and she's like i will
help you
roll credits wait a year for season
three i mean i that that's kind of my
bold prediction
i'd like to see mark hamill turn up in
the show
you know i'd like to see luke after the
fall of endor this is
what is it like four or five years after
uh yeah five years
you know we like six at this point he
wouldn't be uh
he wouldn't be necessarily having kylo
ren
as a sidekick at this point he could
just be sort of like a freelance
jedi roaming around trying to figure out
what's next
you know and if we're gonna like we're
gonna unite you with yoda if he turns up
at the end of season two
how cool would that be i think bo katana
is gonna come back and fight him off
gideon
that's my bold prediction i just want to
see a cool sword fight i love that yeah
i want to see that dark saber
in live action you know yes oh god it'd
be so
cool i want to see it in toy action
it'll be really nice on my shelves i
just need a nice dark saber
yeah you got a lot going on back there
i'm not the only one though come on
we all got it well thank you guys so
much for
taking the time and joining me and um
just to sign off let us
know where we can find you guys jermaine
from my writing on
io9.com and i'm on twitter and instagram
at germain lucier
you can find me anywhere on the internet
if you look for oh katrina that's
o-h-c-a-t-r-i-n-a
and i am writing at vanityfair.com and
in the magazine
and you can find me right here on et
online or et live or wherever you're
watching this and i'm at ash crossing
and i'll see you guys next time
you